so just as we go to air a power-sharing
agreement has been signed in Yemen now
it is between the Yemeni government and
southern separatists this is to do with
Aden the southern parts of the country a
deal brokered by Saudi Arabia it is
aimed at ending a power struggle in the
south the Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman says it is a step towards a
political solution to end the war in
Yemen now this is something that had
opened up essentially a new front in the
Yemen war which has been going on for
years already and as we mentioned it did
pit allies against each other Saudi
Arabia and the United Arab Emirates so
this is called the Riyadh agreements and
we're going to take you through some of
the details now it has been brokered by
Saudi Arabia during weeks of
negotiations aimed at sharing power
between president Abdul Rabbu Mansour
Hadi government and the southern
transitional council the STC under the
plan Yemen's Prime Minister would return
to Aden to reinstate state institutions
cabinet positions would be given to
members of that Southern transitional
council the UAE backed separatist
movement wanted self-rule in southern
Yemen and it turned against Haddie's
government in August as its forces
seized the city of Aden so a lot of
information there but we've got
Katherine shocked them with us now to go
through some of it the head of the Yemen
department at the peace building think
tank next century foundation and
Katherine's also a former UN Security
Council consultant on Yemen so Katherine
perfectly placed to talk us through this
just broad-brush first how significant
how big a deal is this well I think it
is very significant and if anything you
will be I think who blueprint and a
cornerstone for bringing peace EML all
together and I think this is definitely
very useful and I offers some degree of
a consensus maybe not with everybody or
not all the actors involved in this in
this war in Yemen but least some of them
and I think you will allow for I think
reason to return and it demonstrates to
all actors that peace can be brokered
and that a political agreement can can
be hab in between different parties even
though
initially they were sitting on very
different sides of the river and
everything seemed to separate them but
obviously with a little bit of effort
some pragmatism and a good dose of humor
I think that it is it is possible they
certainly have done it and I think it's
a good thing and if I may I think it's
it's interesting to see how the STC
managed to actually implement some of
the points that we discussed back in the
1990s when Yemen decided to unite in
between north and south but some of the
points that the agreed upon were never
actually implemented in terms of sharing
power and so today it's actually quite
significant that the SCC managed to to
return back to those poems have them
implemented by president Hadi and
actually I think cement a resolution in
a peace agreement that would last and is
applicable on the ground and that
answers people demands so how did the
two I'm glad you mentioned though you
know going back to the 90s and the
reunification because we have a very
acute problem in southern Yemen that
started in August but we have these
long-held issues as well as the to sort
of come together with this deal in some
ways I think so I think some of the main
issue that the Secession is always hard
when it came to Tucson our central
government well that they didn't feel
represented and they very much felt
completely disenfranchised and they felt
as well that all the natural resources
that Yemen had at his disposal way
essentially spent on a particular elite
in the north and that they were
completely forgotten and that led to a
great divide in between the north and
the south and Yemen was never ever a
nation state as such and so I think that
today again is very significant because
it proves that even though some degree
of autonomy is not given to the south it
also allows for a central government to
to be ruling over Yemen in participation
if you will of all the different
political parties which is quite healthy
if you want to have a workable
Republican system which is Yemen
essentially so I think what we see is a
transition from the first Republic to
truly the second Republic where
political pluralism would be definitely
cemented
where people have a send you have
political representation but at the same
time the central government is not
giving away its sovereignty but it's
willing to share so that the country as
a whole can move together forward which
i think is absolutely vital when we're
talking about a country such as Yemen
that has been divided for great many
decades and I think the war if anything
excluded those divisions have actually
led them completely bare and this is
creating and has created this nightmare
so far there has been unsolvable but I
think this will allow for a very very
significant bridge to actually take
shape and take hold more importantly
Katherine would you mind staying there
for me just for a moment I'm going to
come back to you in a second but I just
want to bring in our diplomatic editor
James BAE's in New York and actually you
can hear what he has to say as well hi
James just take us through a little bit
more of the detail of the deal and some
of the reaction if you would well I I
haven't seen the detail and I have to be
honest neither have it seems members of
the UN Security Council because just
moments ago on the floor below me here
in UN headquarters the Security Council
were gathering for a separate meeting on
Bosnia certainly it was being left to me
and other members of the media to break
news of this deal to the ambassadors who
certainly hadn't heard the news the only
one who was prepared to react to us in
the last few minutes was the German
ambassador Christoph who's gone who said
he thought that this sounded good but he
hadn't seen the text of the deal and he
wanted to read the text of the deal
first also worth telling you they spoke
to one of those diplomats of the
Security Council countries the 15
countries who actually do a lot of the
heavy lifting organizing things behind
the scenes they called the political
coordinators and this particular
political coordinator said they'll look
at the deal and there may well be
discussion in the coming hours whether
the Security Council should issue some
sort of statement welcoming this deal
but of course this is only a deal
concerning the South of Yemen and if you
go back a year ago to the Stockholm
agreement things were not as serious in
the south as they have been since that
deal so
it's solving part of the problem but not
many of the other problems in Yemen and
the central dispute between the Houthis
and the government of Yemen of course is
not part of this deal we have one other
statement in the last few minutes and
that's from an important person this was
very much a Saudi deal that has been
done also the UAE which was part of the
coalition in this pulling back its
forces clearly was involved the UN I
think more of an observer but the UN
Special Envoy has put out a statement in
the last few moments Martin Griffiths
welcoming this deal congratulating the
government Yemen and the southern
transitional council he goes on in the
statement the signing of this agreement
is an important step for our collective
efforts to advance a peaceful settlement
on the conflict in Yemen listening to
southern stakeholders is important to
the political efforts to achieve peace
in the country of course his efforts
since that deal in December last year in
Stockholm have centered on the port of
who Dada and they haven't managed to
translate that agreement on her data
into a wider peace deal key issues like
the transfer of detainees between
various sides and other wider issues
have been sticking points until now come
on okay thanks for that James BAE's our
diplomatic editor and thanks also to
Catherine shaft on who we spoke to
earlier